Kamala Harris accidentally articulated
the ultimate goal of so many leftist
policies think about the impact on
something like public health when we
invest in clean energy and electric
vehicles and reduce populations what was
that more of our children can breathe
clean air and drink clean water
reduce population she opens up she says
think about the effect on public health
and then as part of Public Health she
suggests we reduce the population
reducing the population means killing
people or at the very the most
charitable way you could read that is
sterilizing people getting people not to
have kids whether physically or just
culturally that's what they want they
really do want to reduce the population
and they've they've said it sometimes
overtly sometimes only implicitly